hello team reject nation its Greg Alba
here I'm John on occasion
John on occasion and I are gonna watch
this video from mark hamill oh he's not
my Luke Skywalker's the quote of this
video oh boy
adding controversy to the controversy
before we do that we would like to give
a shout out to today's awesome video
sponsor I really love this product it's
ggmm the service is really nifty e2
wireless smart speaker I've been playing
around a lot with it so much money you
can connect just about any device to it
phone and tablet a computer anything
that's why Phi or Bluetooth and in the
few weeks of troubleshooting the channel
it's really helped pass the time it's
and the sound of it is great and here's
the fun part the e2 comes Alexa enable
for all you lovely Amazon users nivel
it's been a blast we'll give you guys an
example John often used as much bigger
words than me and videos and I nod my
head acting like I know what he's
talking about now instead of going on a
website looking it up I could just ask
Alexa right here so John spit ball the
word I might not know uh defenestrate oh
that's when you I have no idea
Alexa what does defenestrate mean the
term defense Street means throw through
or out of the window yeah Alexa who is
Mark Hamill mark Richard Hamill is an
American stage screen and voice actor
Alexa do you like Tyrone Magnus
but you guys here I agree I know it's
coming through the mic on ours but the
sound is really superb we can't
obviously play music in this video but
the music sound quality is awesome
and if you have more than one you can
actually connect at least two of them to
your phone or tablet and listen and
stereo plus they have a multi room
listening function if you have a few of
these speakers so that you can listen to
either the same music in multiple rooms
of your house or if you want to listen
to different music away from somebody
else who's already listening you can do
that too you told me it works with iOS
is airplay and androids DLNA DLNA for
all those of you who are using like
Apple music or Spotify title whatever it
is I Heart Radio any of those there's
actually a feature where you can save up
to six of your favorite playlists
favorite channels to the device itself
now they've got an app where you can
manage that stuff but they also have
this nifty little heart-shaped button
right here that'll allow you to you know
instantly save and oscillate through
them and it even lets you do hands-free
calling so this particular speaker has a
10 watt output it comes in a variety of
colors including does it come in black
it comes in black huai pink and this
nifty little blue color and you can find
these eetu wireless smart speakers on
Amazon but click our special link so
that I know we sent you and if you enter
our special code which is ggmm e 2 SS
you know our initials that's right you
will get an extra 20% off which is
pretty rad and they're already
affordable to begin with and they've got
a five star rating currently on Amazon
so it's a worthy investment it makes a
great stocking stuffer for this coming
Monday so let's watch this video
finally I mean even if you had a problem
he would maybe take a year to try and
regroup but if he made a mistake he
would try and write that wrong so right
there we had a fundamental difference
but it's not my story anymore it's
somebody else's story and Brian needed
to be a certain way to make the ending
effective that's the whole crux of my
problem Luke would never say that I'm
sorry well in this version C I'm talking
about this the George Lucas Star Wars
this is the generation of Star Wars so I
almost had to think of Lucas another
character maybe he's Jake Skywalker he's
not my Luke Skywalker but I had to do
what Brian wanted me to do because it
serves the story well but listen I still
have an exception and completely but
it's only a movie I hope people like it
I don't they don't get upset and I came
to really believe that Ryan was the
exact man that they needed for this job
this is not gonna help anyone this is
only gonna make everything more crazy
more loud speculative it was I disagree
but you know it's a new generation I
don't really accept it you know is kind
of shocking because I really do feel
this was the best Luke Skywalker
performance we've got him from Mark
Hamill in terms of sincerity and realism
it's an interesting take on Luke - yeah
age was captivating it was my favorite
part of the movie yeah the heart and
soul I knew that in the beginning he'd
disagree but I was under the impression
they just came to a solid conclusion of
Mark Hamill's like I didn't understand
it first I disagreed but now you know I
actually really see what's coming from
the film's great that's what I thought
he was at but this is nice with the
amount of people that have been upset by
the Luke Skywalker portrayal the
direction it went
I feel like this only adds to that
argument of the people who were upset
like guys even Mark Hamill isn't happy
even Mark Hamill doesn't like it I read
some of the sentences he said in this
interview there's more he said here that
I didn't read it's totally different
though when you read it if you just read
the words yeah you're like okay he's
just giving an explanation of the
journey and it sounds like a really calm
manner Boni speaking here he's so
passionate what he's talking about how
he disagrees it's president guy the
status of Skywalker's is certainly not
lost on him so yeah the enthusiasm does
something to drive the point further I
think what's surprising about is he
clearly feels stronger about the
disagreement than he does about the
decision to go through it yeah
really shows in the tone and the
enthusiasm of disagreement passion when
he's talking ya got me cringing kudos to
him for just giving it his all still and
turning in a great performance-based I
something isn't you know resonant with
him yeah this makes me feel stranger and
now I wonder what Disney is gonna do the
film is still massively successful but
they clearly listened to and consider
feedback so now I wonder what this is
all gonna mean for part 9 and it seems
like there's too much forward momentum
for them to like completely alter the
course or anything like that but I
wonder if 9 might not be as bold because
of this like if even Mark Hamill is like
yeah I'm not too keen on this I don't
know or maybe Disney really wants to
strike out for a new generation I mean
III get torn when I think deeply about
this cuz I don't often we're thinking
about it now yeah if it's a new Star
Wars for a new generation I don't
understand it all the frenzied people
were allowing themselves to be work dude
- but I get feeling a little let down a
little betrayed by the fact that it's a
different fundamental core character I
don't know it's something different when
as opposed to doing prequels which were
upsetting for a lot of people the thing
about the sequels though is it's
continuing the journey from the beloved
trilogy that all the fans had so if they
disagree they're gonna disagree strongly
and especially with the differences they
did with Mark Hamill's character Luke
Skywalker I'm kind of wondering did he
enjoy we're doing this I can't seem to
tell if he ever enjoy everything I've
ever heard for him seems like I know he
loves being a part of Star Wars and he
loved being in the world and he's
excited to return but every time I hear
him talk about this I'm always like I
don't even know if he enjoyed being on
set at this point you know I sure hope
he did I mean he does such a good job in
the movie yeah yeah and I don't know I
mean I've always heard that Rian Johnson
is a good guy and you know consummate
professionals so I would hope that their
work report yeah a good one even if he
disagreed and I don't think that that's
impossible you know the his vibe here is
enthusiastic but I don't think it's to
say like screw what he wanted to do I
think it's dumb I think he just
disagrees you know well I
I don't know to me it seems more along
the lines of he's given his opinion and
then he backs it with what Disney would
want him to say that's what it sounds
like because he has two completely
different tones when he's talking about
it yeah he does seem like a guy who
approaches Star Wars from a fan and
insider perspective simultaneously well
guys how do you feel about the way Mark
Hamill feels please put your comments
down below oh my god I wasn't expected
I'm just like cringing it what are you
saying well you guys can subscribe to
the real rejects you can click that
notification valve make sure to follow
us on social media and last but not
least make sure to enter that special
promo code follow the link the
description box make sure you get
yourself one of them ggmm e to wireless
smart speakers